welcome back the Home Secretary amber
Rudd will be back in the House of
Commons tomorrow to explain the
government's policy with regards to
immigration targets and what they're
doing for the Windrush generation had
join lino to discuss that much more the
party's deputy chairman James cleverly
mister quite very good morning to you
and can you just flesh out for me what
you believe the criteria are for a
minister to resign these days because
frankly I'm a bit confused well I you
try to draw me on on the situation with
the Home Secretary I think what she has
said is absolutely fair and right that
there were communications within the
department that she didn't see she's
apologized for that but ultimately what
she's focusing on is making right this
situation with the Windrush generation
making sure that their immigration
status is regular eyes and making sure
that we do that whilst continuing to do
the very important job of removing
people who have no right to be here
often involved in criminal activities
and that is actually the right thing for
her to be doing I mean the question for
some people is whether or not there has
been a breach of the ministerial code
she says that she did not mislead the
house intentionally and therefore it is
not that would be looked at tomorrow but
I mean the HuffPost spa walkers are
better than me that doesn't seem to be
any consistency if you mislead about
pornography your sack of all if you
endangered a British citizen it around
your not a lack of candid about trips to
Israel gets you the bullet ruining the
lives of windra the Windrush generation
doesn't I mean isn't the truth that it's
simply politically expedient to keep
amber Rudd where she is for the time
being at least though I've worked with
amber rod for a number of years she's an
incredibly diligent focused and
effective a politician the situation
with the Windrush generation was decades
in the making it's a unique and it's a
terrible situation and and we have
apologized for the the pain and
suffering that those people have gone
through the the the job that the Home
Secretary is now doing is making sure
that we sort that problem out whilst
also doing the really important stuff of
you know tackling knife crime tackling
modern slavery tackling those those
those in justices and problems whether
or not she's the
person to do so I mean she has
apologized five times she will issue
what one presumes to be another
groveling apology tomorrow to the house
I mean it's not her defense essentially
but she's incompetent no no no the
targets I accept that I should have been
its incompetence I think Amber's being
very tough and herself which doesn't
surprise me because she's a very
professional person she takes an awful
lot of pride in doing the job well the
the questions that were being asked of
her in the Home Affairs Select Committee
were about internal management metrics
that had been discussed in a previous
evidence session that morning and were
pieces of information which joined the
many thousands of documents that float
around inside the home office to which
many of whom many of those documents are
addressed to her but actually wasn't
seeking a decision it wasn't seeking
funding it was a it was an update I mean
it's a it sounds very much to me but
you're trying to pass the buck to the
civil servant what made that very warm
office I mean she said myself I wasn't
aware Dov target I accept that I should
have been you're saying well you know
there wasn't a decision to be made in
all of this there wasn't it it does
sound as if if amber rod is not to blame
then who is for her not seeing this
stuff no I am absolutely not blaming the
Civil Service in fact it's completely
the opposite so the the the the the memo
was about internal management targets it
was about managers within the department
discharging their duty professionally
and giving a kind of a for information
update up the ministerial chain of
command many of those documents are
created not all of them are seen by by
ministers and indeed certainly not all
of them seen by secretaries of state it
is not passing blame at all in fact it's
about saying that there's a awful lot of
professional decision-making which is
done at many levels within the
department but again to the point of the
amber Rhodes competence or lack thereof
I mean does does she read the read
anything I mean there have been a number
of important documents that she hasn't
seen take for example that Home Office
report which saw a link between cutting
police numbers and violent crimes I mean
she denied seeing that as well
was a leaked report that wasn't sent to
her so here your criticism that she's
he's not seeing documents that she
hasn't been sent I think it's a little
bit harsh okay if we take it face value
that she didn't see the memo and we have
no reason to think otherwise that mean
that doesn't necessarily mean that she
didn't know about the target you know
there's this line in the memo itself it
says that progress has been made on a
path towards the 10% increased
performance on enforced returns which we
promised the Home Secretary earlier this
year
yeah yeah so she knew that was a target
no she she there was a commitment to
improve performance that should be the
aspiration gonna beat how do you know
that you're going to get 10% better if
you don't have a figure in the first
place you could remember she was saying
she was saying about what figures she
was exposed to what information had been
sent to her within departments there are
key performance indicators there are
internal figures so that managers can
manage the people in their in their
charge was a KPI if not a target it's an
indicator it basically it's a
measurement tool and I know this sounds
semantics but it's important because
because the difference between what the
Home Secretary said and what people are
implying she said and criticizing her
for their interpretation of what was
actually said I think it's a subtle but
a very significant difference I mean it
strikes me that perhaps is getting a bit
crowded on the head of that pin but
let's let's deal with a letter coming
from the 200 m piece suggesting that the
commitments made to the Windrush
generation should be put into law I mean
that that's probably fail isn't it given
that they probably don't have much
reason to trust you right now well the
really important thing is that the Home
Secretary and the rest of the Home
Office team are doing everything they
can to regularize these status to make
sure that this can never happen again to
make sure that the people who have got
to go through a process do so without
being charged and that we put it right I
think it is better to spend the time and
effort delivering for the people who
through no fault of their own have been
disadvantaged by the circumstance rather
than preparing a
because frankly that is I understand the
motivation the people are not
questioning their motivation I just
think resources we better spent dealing
with this situation we have spoken time
again on this program about the problems
with in labor ranks about about
anti-semitism and the Conservatives have
talked about it as well but isn't it the
case that the Conservatives themselves
have a problem with with Islamophobia
well there are individuals in all
political parties you know these are big
organizations that say and do things
which are completely inappropriate the
question is how you deal with that we
have got a player you can see that you
have a problem with Islamophobia I mean
Baroness verse he said last week I know
within my own party there are no almost
weekly occurrences of his llama phobic
incidents and rhetoric that sounds like
a problem to me no I don't believe I
don't that's I don't agree with that as
as an assessment what the point I was
going to make is that where people have
behaved inappropriately our party we
have a respect pledge we deal very
quickly we suspend people who have done
something that we believe to be
inappropriate and if an investigation
confirms that than they are ejected from
the party I'm very proud of the fact
that we take a tough line on people who
behave inappropriately I mean George
Stokely who was spirits can still
standing for election in Cambridgeshire
no longer as a Conservative candidate
wrote that tweet saying he was sweating
like a Jew in an attic I mean how do
these people get past the vetting
process well as I say when individuals
say and do things inappropriately and
that is self-evidently inappropriate
they are suspended they are given an
opportunity to explain themselves and
then if they fail to live up to the
standards that we demand of them they
are ejected from the party the reason
he's still standing as a candidate as
this came to light after the close of
nominations but we have made it clear we
deal with our problems we are open and
we are transparent about how we deal
with those problems and it would be nice
if all political parties were able to do
so in the way that we have I wonder if I
might be able to encourage you to little
bit further than the Shadow Chancellor
and give us an idea of how you think the
Conservatives will do in the local
elections this week I mean the x the x
mark Charlie Charlie wrote this
fantastic quarter on Thursday back in
February and has to senior Tory if
things were going to be bad for them May
the 3rd
all they said much worse I mean really
effing bad particularly in London London
is just a complete disaster really
effing bad not the phraseology not quite
the phraseology that I'm going to use
it's predicting election results is now
I think a bit of a fool's errand because
they are so difficult to call we've seen
the polling numbers we know London is
going to be a tough fight for us we know
that the the Labour Party have been
bragging about how they're going to get
pretty much a clean sweep across London
we are fighting very very hard
we have fielded a more complete slate of
candidates and I think ever before
certainly in my time in politics we're
fighting hard for every seat and we're
fighting hard on that simple but
compelling argument that we deliver
better local services at less money than
labour councils if people if people
listen to that message that I think
we've got a good chance of doing well
but we recognise that eight years into
government it's a really tough backdrop
and I have to just bring up this picture
that we happen to have this is fantastic
young and I'm not quite sure what's
going on there a bit but it looks like
you've got his vote at the very least
maybe thanks for being with us thank you